And what I say is that you have to start with a goal. That you're asking me, how do I learn to program C++? But that's the wrong question. You need to first figure out, what do you want to do with C++? You need something concrete that you want to build with programming. And this should be something, I think, that matters to you based on your interests and passions. And yeah, I completely agree with everything you said in your message, Bryce. If you want to learn to program, find something you are passionate about.
我的观点是，你必须从一个目标开始。你问我，我该如何学习 C++ 编程？但这个问题问错了。你需要先弄清楚，你想用 C++ 做什么？你需要一些具体的、想通过编程构建的东西。我认为，这应该基于你的兴趣和热情，对你来说是有意义的事情。是的，布莱斯，我完全同意你在信息中所说的一切。如果你想学习编程，就找一件你充满热情的事情去做。
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 186, recorded on both June 7th and June 12th of 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we exchange thoughts on how to get started in programming. It's Friday, June 7th, and I am feeling reflective this morning. This week, you and I recorded a phone tag episode because we've both been pretty busy. I'm in the middle of a move. You've been traveling. You know, I'm really proud of us that we've kept this podcast going and kept publishing every week. Um, despite all the stuff that's going on in our lives. Um, and I'm also really grateful for all of our listeners.
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 186 期，录制于 2024 年 6 月 7 日和 6 月 12 日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯交流了关于如何入门编程的想法。今天是 6 月 7 日星期五，今天早上我感触颇多。这周，你和我录制了一期“电话标签”式的节目，因为我们都太忙了。我正忙着搬家，你也在旅行。你知道，我真的很为我们感到骄傲，我们坚持录制了这个播客，并且每周都在发布。嗯，尽管我们的生活中发生了这么多事情。嗯，我也非常感谢我们所有的听众。
Uh, I was looking at, uh, our reviews on various platforms the other day. Um, and it, it just, it,
呃，前几天我查看了我们在各个平台上的评论。嗯，它，它只是，它，
it warmed my heart to, uh, to see how many people enjoy this, uh, podcast. Um, yeah, it just, it made me feel good and it makes me want to, uh, to deliver the best content that we can. You know, we, we, we joke about me, uh, half-assing it sometimes, but, uh, I, I really do care about this podcast and our listeners. I decided I was going to record this morning because of a conversation that I was having
它让我感到心里暖暖的，呃，看到有这么多人喜欢这个，呃，播客。嗯，是的，它让我感觉很好，也让我想要，呃，提供我们能做到的最好的内容。你知道，我们，我们，我们有时会开玩笑说我，呃，敷衍了事，但，呃，我，我确实很在乎这个播客和我们的听众。我决定今天早上录音，是因为我正在进行的一场谈话，
with my girlfriend, who is about to leave her job and go pursue a career in sports management, let's say. She really loves tennis. She's loved tennis her whole life. She's a tennis coach. She's got all this experience in process engineering and efficiency in business operations. And so she wants to do some sort of tennis coaching or event organizing or consulting. But one thing that she's asked me about a couple times over the past few weeks and months is she wants to learn how to program.
和我女朋友，她即将辞职去追求体育管理方面的职业，比如说。她真的很喜欢网球。她一生都热爱网球。她是一名网球教练。她在流程工程和商业运营效率方面拥有丰富的经验。所以她想做一些网球教练、赛事组织或咨询方面的工作。但过去几周和几个月里，她问过我几次的一件事是，她想学习编程。
So this week, I was coming up with a plan for how she could get started programming. And I told her this morning, something that I tell pretty much anyone who comes and asks me about learning to program, I oftentimes have students, or people who are new to the industry who approach me and say, like, what's the best way to learn C plus plus, like, what's the best book or, or tutorial or resource. And I always tell them the same thing. And what I say is that you have to start with a goal that you're asking me, how do I learn to program C plus plus, but that's the wrong question. You need to first figure out what do you want to do with C plus plus, you need something concrete that you want to build with programming. And this should be something I think that matters to you based on your interests and passions, or maybe
所以这周，我一直在为她制定一个如何开始编程的计划。今天早上我告诉她，我几乎告诉每一个来问我如何学习编程的人同样的话，我经常有学生，或者刚进入这个行业的人来找我，说，比如，学习 C++ 的最好方法是什么，比如，最好的书、教程或资源是什么。我总是告诉他们同样的事情。我的观点是，你必须从一个目标开始，你问我，我该如何学习 C++ 编程，但这是错误的问题。你需要先弄清楚你想用 C++ 做什么，你需要一些具体的、想通过编程构建的东西。我认为这应该基于你的兴趣和热情，对你来说是有意义的事情，或者也许
based on the particular, you know, sector of the industry that you'd want to be in. But I really think it works best if it's something that you're passionate about. Maybe you really like robotics and you want to learn to program a robot. Or maybe you want, you have some project where you want to program an Arduino to automate some task in your house. Maybe you love cooking and you haven't been able to find a recipe app that does exactly what you want, and it's like always really bothered you. Or maybe you're really into fitness. And you want to do some analysis of some fitness data that you have from a bunch of different fitness apps. And this is actually how I started. And we've talked about this on the podcast before.
基于你想要进入的特定行业领域。但我真的认为，如果这是你充满热情的事情，效果最好。也许你真的很喜欢机器人，想学习如何编程机器人。或者也许你想要，你有一些项目，想通过编程 Arduino 来自动化家里的某些任务。也许你热爱烹饪，却一直找不到一个能完全满足你需求的食谱应用程序，这总是让你很困扰。或者也许你真的很喜欢健身。你想对从各种健身应用程序中获取的健身数据进行一些分析。这其实就是我开始的方式。我们之前在播客中谈到过这一点。
Back when I was an 18-year-old, I, throughout my childhood, was really into text-based games. These games called MUDs, which were these sort of online multiplayer games. It's this weird space of gaming where you didn't pay for them. They were just sort of run by volunteers. They'd be hosted on a server. They were very simple because there was no graphics. It was just, you know, a text server and you'd connect to it with Telnet. And I really loved MUDs and I wanted to learn how to create my own MUD. And somebody at some point told me, if you're going to create your own MUD, you might work with some coders, but you really should learn how to code yourself. And that's why I started to learn how to program. And then, you
当我 18 岁的时候，整个童年时期，我一直非常沉迷于基于文本的游戏。这些游戏被称为 MUD，也就是所谓的在线多人游戏。这是一个奇怪的游戏领域，你不需要付费。它们只是由志愿者运营，托管在服务器上。它们非常简单，因为没有图形。它只是，你知道，一个文本服务器，你用 Telnet 连接到它。我真的很喜欢 MUD，我想学习如何创建自己的 MUD。有人在某个时候告诉我，如果你要创建自己的 MUD，你可能会和一些程序员合作，但你真的应该自己学习编程。这就是我开始学习编程的原因。然后，你
know, through that goal, I, you know, I had the motivation. And then eventually, I became sidetracked, I discovered Boost, I got involved with all these other things. I never did end up making that mud, but I would not have found my path in software engineering if I hadn't started off with that goal. That was something that I was passionate about that sort of dictated the course of my education. You know, I haven't talked in greater detail about those early days. We talked a little bit about how when I was, my first exposure to Boost was some Boost string algorithm that one of my colleagues who was working on the mud with me was using this string algorithm and there was some bug in it and I reported the bug up to Boost and then I fixed the bug in Boost and then I became a Boost contributor, eventually started
知道，通过那个目标，我，你知道，我有了动力。后来，我被其他事情分心了，我发现了 Boost，我参与了所有这些其他事情。我最终并没有做出那个 MUD，但如果我没有从那个目标开始，我就不会找到我在软件工程方面的道路。那是我充满热情的事情，它在某种程度上决定了我教育的进程。你知道，我还没有更详细地谈论过那些早期的日子。我们谈到过一点，当我第一次接触 Boost 时，是我的一位同事在和我一起做 MUD 时使用的一个 Boost 字符串算法，那个字符串算法里有一个 bug，我把这个 bug 报告给了 Boost，然后我修复了 Boost 中的那个 bug，然后我成为了 Boost 的贡献者，最终开始
working on Boost Spirit. But we've talked about that, but we haven't talked about a few other things. Like when I was still in those early phases and I was thinking about making my own MUD, I was looking, you know, the core of a MUD is this networking engine where you need to be able to accept, you know, TCP connections over Telnet. And then you have to have some event loop where you process events. And I remember one of the early things that I did was to implement secure sockets in this MUT engine. And so I used some SSL library. I'm sure it was OpenSSL, which there was really no reason to do this. You know, this wasn't like high security.
从事 Boost Spirit 的工作。但我们谈过那个，但我们还没有谈过其他一些事情。比如当我还在那些早期阶段，考虑制作自己的 MUD 时，我正在研究，你知道，MUD 的核心是这个网络引擎，你需要能够接受，你知道，通过 Telnet 的 TCP 连接。然后你必须有一个事件循环来处理事件。我记得我做的早期事情之一是在这个 MUD 引擎中实现安全套接字。所以我使用了一些 SSL 库。我肯定那是 OpenSSL，其实根本没有理由这样做。你知道，这并不是什么高安全性。
This was before like secure sockets everywhere was a thing. But I decided I was going to do this because it seemed like it'd be fun. And then at some point, I think I tried to like implement some parts of the SSL protocol on my own or some cryptographic algorithm. And, you know, that early learning about networking, and sort of low level programming and cryptography, that kind of led me to a lot of my other work in distributed systems. When I was working on HPX. You know, I was, a large part of my responsibility with HPX was around the addressing system and the networking layer. And a lot of that, you know, comes from my early days playing around with MUDs. And the, you know, the thing that
这发生在到处都是安全套接字成为常态之前。但我决定这样做，因为这看起来很有趣。然后在某个时候，我想我尝试自己实现 SSL 协议的某些部分或某种加密算法。而且，你知道，那种关于网络、底层编程和密码学的早期学习，在某种程度上引导我完成了在分布式系统方面的许多其他工作。当我从事 HPX 工作时。你知道，我在 HPX 的大部分职责是围绕寻址系统和网络层。而这一切，你知道，都源于我早期玩 MUD 的日子。而且，你知道，那件事
really, you know, launched my career was once I made the connection with Boost Spirit, in particular with HeartMid. And the reason that I started using Boost Spirit was because of that string algorithm, that first string algorithm, the Boost string algorithm, that was my first exposure to Boost that I found the bug in. I think it was like a split thing, like it would take a string and it would split it up in some way and tokenize it. And I needed this. We were using it when we were parsing the inputs from players in this MUD engine. And the split thing didn't exactly, you know, parse in the way that I wanted. And, you know, there was some bug with it.
真正，你知道，开启我职业生涯的是，一旦我与 Boost Spirit 建立了联系，特别是与 Hartmut。我开始使用 Boost Spirit 的原因是因为那个字符串算法，第一个字符串算法，Boost 字符串算法，那是我第一次接触 Boost 并发现 bug 的地方。我想那是一个类似 split 的东西，它会获取一个字符串并以某种方式将其拆分并标记化。我需要这个。我们在解析这个 MUD 引擎中玩家的输入时使用了它。而那个 split 的东西并不完全，你知道，按照我想要的方式解析。而且，你知道，它有一些 bug。
I fixed the bug. But then somebody at some point said, like, you know, for your use case, you might want to use something like Boost Spirit to parse the input. And so I started looking into that, and playing around with Boost Spirit. And then that's how I got involved as a contributor to Boost Spirit. And then that's how I met Hartmut. And, uh, Hartmut was the one where when I, once I dropped out of college and I needed a job, I asked him, uh, you know, if, if I could, if he knew anybody who was hiring and he said, come on down to Louisiana. And that wouldn't have happened if I hadn't been, uh, a contributor to Spirit, if he didn't know me and know that I was, you know, a good budding programmer. And I wouldn't have been a contributor to Boost Spirit if I hadn't
我修复了那个 bug。但后来有人在某个时候说，你知道，对于你的用例，你可能想使用像 Boost Spirit 这样的东西来解析输入。所以我开始研究它，并尝试使用 Boost Spirit。然后这就是我作为 Boost Spirit 贡献者参与其中的方式。然后这就是我遇到 Hartmut 的方式。而且，呃，Hartmut 是那个人，当我，一旦我从大学退学并且需要一份工作时，我问他，呃，你知道，如果，如果他认识任何正在招聘的人，他说，来路易斯安那州吧。如果我没有成为 Spirit 的贡献者，如果他不认识我，不知道我是一个，你知道，有前途的好程序员，这一切就不会发生。如果我没有
been using that Boost string algorithm. And I wouldn't have been using that Boost string algorithm if it hadn't been in this MUD engine that I was working on. And so it all came back to that original goal. That original, you know, goal, that's what motivated me. That's what drove my learning. That's what pushed me towards C++. Because a lot of these MUD engines having to deal with, you know, low level things like networking, they were written in C++. And that sort of launched the entire trajectory of my career. And so when somebody comes to me and asks me, you know, generically, how do I learn programming? How do I become better at C++? That's almost always the wrong question and the wrong approach. And I always answer it back with that question of what matters
使用那个 Boost 字符串算法，我就不会成为 Boost Spirit 的贡献者。如果我没有在那个我正在开发的 MUD 引擎中使用那个 Boost 字符串算法，我就不会使用它。所以这一切都回到了最初的那个目标。那个最初的，你知道，目标，那才是激励我的东西。那才是推动我学习的东西。那才是将我推向 C++ 的东西。因为许多这些 MUD 引擎必须处理，你知道，像网络这样的底层事物，它们是用 C++ 编写的。这在某种程度上开启了我整个职业生涯的轨迹。所以当有人来问我，你知道，泛泛地问，我该如何学习编程？我该如何提高 C++ 水平？这几乎总是错误的问题和错误的方法。我总是用那个问题来回答，什么对你来说
to you? What do you want to do with C++, with programming, with your pursuit in this software engineering field? What matters to you? Because you have to find something that matters to you. Now, in the case of my girlfriend, the answer is tennis. She's passionate about tennis. She loves tennis. She's about to try to start a career in tennis.
重要？你想用 C++、编程、在这个软件工程领域的追求做什么？什么对你来说重要？因为你必须找到对你来说重要的事情。现在，就我女朋友的情况而言，答案是网球。她对网球充满热情。她热爱网球。她即将尝试开启网球职业生涯。
And so I suggested to her that I think that what you should do is think about what sort of tennis-related programming project could you take on as a goal. And the framework that we're going to use to teach her is Swift Playgrounds, which is something we talked about with Doug a couple episodes ago. And I'll tell you why I picked Swift Playgrounds. I spent a couple days sort of researching best approaches to teach non-programmers how to program, to teach somebody who has no programming background how to program. And I wanted to find something for Python. And one of the reasons is that I am now doing more Python stuff at NVIDIA. And I don't know that much about Python. And so it would be good for me
所以我建议她，我认为你应该做的是思考一下，你可以承担什么样的网球相关编程项目作为目标。我们将用来教她的框架是 Swift Playgrounds，这是我们几期节目之前和道格谈论过的内容。我会告诉你为什么我选择了 Swift Playgrounds。我花了两天时间研究教非程序员如何编程的最佳方法，教一个没有任何编程背景的人如何编程。我想为 Python 找点东西。原因之一是我现在在 NVIDIA 做更多 Python 相关的事情。我对 Python 了解不多。所以对我来说
to learn a bit about Python. But I ended up on Swift Playgrounds. And the reason was, you know, I started searching for like, you know, how to learn to program, you know, how to learn to program for non-programmers. And just like a bazillion results come up. There's, you know, paid courses. There's free content. There's code camps with instructors. There's YouTube videos.
学习一点 Python 会很好。但我最终选择了 Swift Playgrounds。原因在于，你知道，我开始搜索，比如，你知道，如何学习编程，你知道，非程序员如何学习编程。结果简直多如牛毛。有，你知道，付费课程。有免费内容。有带讲师的编程训练营。有 YouTube 视频。
There's all sorts of other interactive content. There's more static content like articles and tutorials and books. It's frankly overwhelming. And the challenge for me was that I was looking through all the possible options. And there were some things that I'd heard of before, like Khan Academy and Udemy. Some of them that are things that I thought highly of. But it was hard for me to judge three things. One, how good is the content? Two, is the content at the right level? Will it be suitable for somebody who's got no prior programming experience? And three, how much setup is involved for the content? Do you have to install a development environment? Do you have to download stuff? What type of computer do you have to have, etc. So I felt overwhelmed. And I decided that I was just going to check out Swift Playgrounds
有各种各样的互动内容。有更多静态内容，如文章、教程和书籍。坦率地说，这让人不知所措。对我来说，挑战在于我正在查看所有可能的选项。有些是我以前听说过的，比如可汗学院和 Udemy。其中一些是我评价很高的。但我很难判断三件事。第一，内容有多好？第二，内容水平是否合适？它适合没有任何编程经验的人吗？第三，内容需要多少设置？你必须安装开发环境吗？你必须下载东西吗？你必须拥有什么样的电脑等等。所以我感到不知所措。我决定我只是去看看 Swift Playgrounds
because I'd seen some demos of it before. I thought highly of it. I figured I'd give it a shot. It was super easy to get set up. I just downloaded it and that was it. I have the entire development environment. I don't have to set up anything else there. Second, I love that it has a visual component to it.
因为我以前看过它的一些演示。我评价很高。我想我还是试一试吧。设置起来超级简单。我只是下载了它，就这样。我拥有了整个开发环境。我不需要在那里设置任何其他东西。第二，我喜欢它有一个视觉组件。
And I think that makes it so much more approachable. And third, I could just tell immediately that this was quality curated content. And that's sort of what you'd expect from Apple. And the fact that it's from Apple, that means that it's going to be so nicely integrated into the development environment that my girlfriend would be using, which is either a MacBook or an iPad. And so within like three minutes of playing around with Swift Playgrounds, I was convinced that this was the thing to use to teach her. And the fact that it's like the official thing from Swift and from Apple was like a big deciding factor there. If when I had Googled for, you know, how to learn Python for beginners, if there had been like one clear thing that was like an interactive experience that was easy to download and set up. And it was something that was from, you know, the Python Software Foundation. And, you know,
我认为这让它变得更容易接近。第三，我可以立刻看出这是高质量的策划内容。这正是你对苹果的期望。而且它是来自苹果的事实，意味着它将非常完美地集成到我女朋友将要使用的开发环境中，也就是 MacBook 或 iPad。所以，在玩了大约三分钟 Swift Playgrounds 后，我就确信这就是教她的东西。而且它是来自 Swift 和苹果的官方产品这一事实是一个很大的决定因素。如果当我搜索，你知道，初学者如何学习 Python 时，如果有一个明确的东西，比如一个易于下载和设置的互动体验。而且它是来自，你知道，Python 软件基金会。而且，你知道，
clearly was something that was anointed by, you know, the Python language itself. I might have gone with that. So the plan is that she's going to learn Swift with Swift Playgrounds. And then she's going to come up with some idea for some sort of tennis app. Hopefully something that's going to be fairly simple and straightforward and achievable. And then we're going to try to build it together. And we'll see how that goes. And maybe I'll learn a bit about Swift in the process. So I'm not really sure why I'm recording this.
显然是得到了，你知道，Python 语言本身认可的东西。我可能就会选择那个了。所以计划是她将通过 Swift Playgrounds 学习 Swift。然后她会想出一个关于某种网球应用程序的想法。希望是一个相当简单、直接且可实现的想法。然后我们将尝试一起构建它。我们会看看进展如何。也许我会在这个过程中学到一点 Swift。所以我真的不确定我为什么要录这个。
I guess I was excited to share with you this sort of message that I give to newcomers about setting a goal for yourself when you get started in programming. And I just wanted to share that with you and share that with the listeners. The listeners who I am very grateful for. Hey, Connor, it's Bryce again. I did listen to the last phone tag episode. So I did hear you wishing me the best of luck with the move.
我想我很兴奋能与你分享我给新手的这种信息，关于当你开始编程时为自己设定一个目标。我只是想和你分享，并与听众分享。我非常感谢的听众们。嘿，康纳，我是布莱斯。我确实听了上一期“电话标签”节目。所以我确实听到了你祝我搬家顺利。
So, ha, there. And I even listened to it the best of luck with the move. So, ha! And I even listened to it the day that the episode came out. So, what do you know? Talk to you later, buddy. Alrighty. We are here in Oslo, Norway. Just got your message. Actually, I got it a few days ago.
所以，哈，在那儿。我甚至在节目发布的那天就听了。所以，你知道什么？回头聊，伙计。好的。我们现在在挪威奥斯陆。刚收到你的信息。其实我几天前就收到了。
But I have been traveling and have not had time to reply until now. We are walking. What time is it? I believe it's like 8.45 a.m. and we are headed to day one of the three-day NDC Oslo conference. It's Wednesday, June 12th, I think, and we are only a couple minutes away, so this is going to be a pretty short recording.
但我一直在旅行，直到现在才有时间回复。我们正在走路。现在几点了？我相信大约是早上 8 点 45 分，我们正前往为期三天的 NDC 奥斯陆会议的第一天。我想今天是 6 月 12 日星期三，我们离目的地只有几分钟路程了，所以这将是一段很短的录音。
My talk is tomorrow at 1.40 p.m. local time, entitled The Power of Function Composition, the revised version of the talk that I gave at CraftConf a couple weeks ago. And yeah, I completely agree with everything you said in your message, Bryce. If you want to learn to program, find something you are passionate about. I have several of these kinds of projects. You mentioned your mud game, which led you down the C++ rabbit hole all the way to boost spirit. My passion these days is city striding. I ran 20k this morning, woke up at 5.45am, collected 44 streets, and I'm inside now. Gotta keep my voice down.
我的演讲是在明天当地时间下午 1 点 40 分，题目是《函数组合的力量》，这是我几周前在 CraftConf 上演讲的修订版。是的，布莱斯，我完全同意你在信息中所说的一切。如果你想学习编程，就找一件你充满热情的事情去做。我有几个这样的项目。你提到了你的 MUD 游戏，它引导你走进了 C++ 的兔子洞，一直到 Boost Spirit。我最近的热情是城市漫步（City Striding）。我今天早上跑了 20 公里，早上 5 点 45 分起床，收集了 44 条街道，现在我在室内。得压低声音。
Honestly, I'm looking for a 7-Eleven. I need to stop recording this so that I can successfully find this institution. I see. It's downstairs. Anyways, we'll keep talking, just at a lower voice. Yeah, ran 20k this morning. Also ran 20k yesterday. Yesterday was a more successful city striding day.
老实说，我在找 7-Eleven。我需要停止录音，这样我才能成功找到这个机构。我看到了。它在楼下。总之，我们会继续谈话，只是声音小一点。是的，今天早上跑了 20 公里。昨天也跑了 20 公里。昨天是更成功的一天城市漫步。
79 streets. I don't know what I'm ranked in Oslo. Yesterday was a more successful city striding day. 79 streets. I don't know what I'm ranked in Oslo. But, yeah. We have a GitHub repository. I think I've mentioned it on the podcast before. A program that generates routes. Typically I've been hand rollingrolling my own roots these days because my algorithm doesn't work, you know, as good as a heat map-assisted human,
79 条街道。我不知道我在奥斯陆排名多少。昨天是更成功的一天城市漫步。79 条街道。我不知道我在奥斯陆排名多少。但是，是的。我们有一个 GitHub 仓库。我想我之前在播客中提到过它。一个生成路线的程序。通常我最近都是自己手动规划路线，因为我的算法工作得，你知道，不如热图辅助的人类好，
but I still generate the heat maps. Oh, look at that. I could have gone right underground, right past this 7-Eleven. Anyways, we generate these heat maps using Python, Plotly Express. Honestly, GPT wrote most of it for me. But hey, that's programming these. Oh, my goodness. Look at the line here. Nothing to do but wait. All right. Look at the line here. Nothing to do but wait. Alright.
但我仍然生成热图。哦，看那个。我本可以直接走地下，直接经过这个 7-Eleven。总之，我们使用 Python 和 Plotly Express 生成这些热图。老实说，GPT 为我写了大部分代码。但嘿，这就是现在的编程。哦，天哪。看看这里的队伍。除了等待别无他法。好的。看看这里的队伍。除了等待别无他法。好的。
We're waiting in line at the 7-Eleven behind. Six people now. And yeah. I update this GitHub repo pretty actively with data for Toronto. When I was in
我们正在 7-Eleven 排队，后面有六个人。是的。我非常积极地更新这个 GitHub 仓库，包含多伦多的数据。当我在
Monterey slash Pacific Grove, did a lot of city striding there, Santa Clara, city striding there. Anyways, I'm obsessed. And, I mean, I'm not learning how to program, but if someone was trying to learn how to program, and they had some kind of obsessive hobby like this, writing some kind of Python script or application to optimize things.
蒙特雷/太平洋丛林时，在那里做了很多城市漫步，圣克拉拉，在那里做了城市漫步。总之，我着迷了。而且，我的意思是，我不是在学习如何编程，但如果有人试图学习如何编程，并且他们有某种像这样的强迫性爱好，编写某种 Python 脚本或应用程序来优化事情。
No better way. No better way, folks. Yeah, I also got my Scrabble game. Had some Python as well. And it's called Hookstar. I haven't worked on that recently. But link in the description. Link in the description.
没有比这更好的方法了。没有比这更好的方法了，伙计们。是的，我还有我的拼字游戏。也有一些 Python 代码。它叫 Hookstar。我最近没怎么做那个。但描述中有链接。描述中有链接。
I gave a talk at Code Dive a couple years ago. And, yeah. So whether it's Swift, I honestly, I'd probably recommend Python. All things being equal. But if your girlfriend or you, the listener, are on a Mac, or I guess typically wouldn't be the listener. If you're the listener listening to this podcast, odds are you already code.
我几年前在 Code Dive 做过一次演讲。而且，是的。所以无论是 Swift，老实说，我可能还是会推荐 Python。在所有条件相同的情况下。但如果你的女朋友或者你，听众，是在 Mac 上，或者我猜通常不会是听众。如果你是听这个播客的听众，很可能你已经会写代码了。
So if you have a friend as a listener that is thinking about getting into programming, I'd probably recommend them Python. But Swift is great. They got Swift UI. What else would I recommend? Would I recommend any other language other than Python? If they're trying to get into low-level stuff,
所以如果你有一个听众朋友正在考虑进入编程领域，我可能还是会推荐他们 Python。但 Swift 很棒。他们有 Swift UI。我还推荐什么？除了 Python，我还会推荐其他语言吗？如果他们想进入底层的东西，
I'd probably recommend Rust. And definitely use ChatGPT. All right, I've got to buy my beverages here. Awesome. Have a good day. Thank you. All right. Did we leave all that stuff in? Maybe. The English cashier was surprised at my use of the word howdy. Anyways, Python Swift plus an LLM. I use Perplexity these days because I get a free subscription
我可能会推荐 Rust。而且一定要使用 ChatGPT。好了，我得去买饮料了。太棒了。祝你有美好的一天。谢谢。好的。我们把那些东西都录进去了吗？也许吧。那个英语收银员对我说“howdy”感到惊讶。总之，Python Swift 加一个大语言模型。我最近使用 Perplexity，因为我通过工作获得了免费订阅，
through work, and I use the Cloud 3 opus model in my opinion it is far superior to any other model everyone says gpt 4.0 is good i think it's straight trash i don't know if it's because i started using it instantly when it was released but it was just spewing hot garbage for a quick minute. Whereas Cloud 3 Opus, it's the largest language model that is released in the Cloud series. It's freaking fantastic, folks. It does basically all the work for you. Anyways, probably Bryce's advice was better than mine. These are just the ramblings of a person walking to a conference, but
我使用 Claude 3 Opus 模型，在我看来它远优于任何其他模型。每个人都说 GPT 4.0 很好，我觉得它简直是垃圾。我不知道是不是因为我刚发布就立刻开始使用它，但它有一会儿简直是在胡言乱语。而 Claude 3 Opus，它是 Claude 系列中发布的最大语言模型。它简直太棒了，伙计们。它基本上为你完成了所有的工作。总之，布莱斯的建议可能比我的好。这些只是一个走去参加会议的人的胡言乱语，但是
yeah, good luck to the potentially first-time listeners of this podcast if regular listeners sent this to their friends who are looking to get into programming and have never
是的，祝这个播客的潜在新听众好运，如果老听众把这个发给了他们那些想进入编程领域却从未
programmed before. All right, I got to go. Bye. This side with a badge, that side with a ticket. Thank you. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed, and have a great day.
编过程的朋友。好了，我得走了。再见。这边带徽章，那边带票。谢谢。请务必在你的播客应用程序或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上查看这些节目说明，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。
Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。那不是口号。我们的口号是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。